de 7 heures du matin à 21h l'arracheuse
poursuit son incessant ballet les pommes
de terre ne peuvent pas tu abordes un
énorme engin d trigger ce sont des
petites mains expertes et entraîné le
travail est physique avant la récolte
la terre doit d'être arrosée dans cette
parcelle là où on a d amandine la pomme
de terre est très très fragile a une
peau très très fragile et si on la
récolte dans les conditions trop sèche
la peau va être arrachés abîmé et le
tubercule sera non commercialisables sur
cette parcelle d'une dizaine d'hectares
seront récoltés d amandine l'une des
quarante variétés de tubercules produits
en région centre val de loire à chaque
récolte c'est la sempiternelle équation
la quantité la qualité des prix seront
ils au rendez vous
pour l'instant nous avons plutôt des
rendements normaux pourquoi parce que
dans la région tout est irrigué toutes
les productions de pommes de terres sont
irriguées donc ça ça nous permet
d'assurer à un rendement normal
quelles que soient les conditions
climatiques la qualité est plutôt
satisfaisante
quand on les récolte et qui fait trop
chaud le tubercule a tendance à se
déshydrater faut pas oublier qu'une
pomme de terre c'est 80% d'eau donc si
on la récolte par trop forte température
à se déshydrate
et après on va avoir des problèmes lors
du stockage des pommes de terre pour
l'instant le prix est plutôt orienté à
la baisse parce que les producteurs
beaucoup de producteurs dans la région
n'assure pas forcément leur débouché
commercial
donc si l'offre est plus importante que
la demande c'est classique
le prix a tendance à baisser dans chaque
caisse applique padox 5 tonnes de pommes
de terre fraîchement récolter avec 700
mille tonnes de patates produites chaque
année
notre région est la 3e ex-aequo avec
champagne ardenne loin derrière les
hauts de france